you know my story but not my name You
Know Who I am
but now my journey my name is PewDiePie
anime Hunter you think I can't beat this
stupid game
I will not be defeated but some cartoon
ass looking baked chess looking game
that I seriously die a hundred and seven
times last episode whatever whatever
their own ass
it doesn't count here we go I got it
I get it I got a ride link I got a ride
link to the other side okay okay you
[ __ ] [ __ ] why why did he do that
then what am I supposed to do what a
dick
link you're don't the hell am I supposed
to do then no where am I supposed to go
what if I shoot him oh my god where do I
go then over here oh my god oh I track
you i trick your linky boy what the [ __ ]
I don't get it why is this game
impossible
[Music]
I get it this is easy right
[ __ ] off I need a sword right I need the
[ __ ] sword you know what [ __ ] this
I'm going back [ __ ] this I'm out okay
fine I'll go back maybe I can walk on
the spikes maybe I can shoot this bike
what the hell I broke the game I broke
the game and bro I broke the dam oh my
god what do I do
okay I get it I get it I get it I get it
[ __ ] off it's a tricky jump but I can do
it
[ __ ] yes yes
[ __ ] you Linc [ __ ] you and devout off
it's so hard to time this jump okay okay
okay okay okay okay let me go let me go
am I gonna have to do this stupid jump
every time I'm so [ __ ] happy that
this is happening game broke again what
a great game I love this I love this I
live for this [ __ ]
hell yeah this is so much fun oh it's
hard too hard for you Felix you should
go and play pokemon Mandy Neil I am
laughs on the auto fan better Devereaux
fan whatevs Cole appalling
yeah that last spike how do I fun how do
I even it's not even physically possible
go away link God into me oh my side can
you jump if you jump off something I
want to see this I can so I think I need
to walk off him and then jump genius
strategic I know I've been playing a few
games in my life look at me do this on
the first try
first try mother truckers first try Bert
shut up shut up second try zero deaths
zero death [ __ ] 0 that 0 deaths first
try first try zero death [ __ ] Sarah
teacher that's the first trap first trap
for strap watch me to your first try
first right first right first right dad
I first read zero death [ __ ] it's the
first try sir de reserved 0.000000 fun y
link i thought we loved each other
no so close to do this limit I can do
this s way to battle the power of garden
enemy I will do this I will conquer 9 9
f liner pine air because liner big
designer
no no link no what is happening with
this a glitchy ass game the beach
[ __ ] activate your Lourdes order whoa
whoa what the what oh my god I had it
this is so hard
stop judging me
ah link this is good
da [ __ ] you link give me the same hell
yeah that's what I'm talking about zero
deaths they're all death here Oh Oh easy
game it's easy this game is easy okay
okay what's gonna kill me now I wonder
what's going to give me oh maybe the
fans Oh No
maybe the spike is no my gosh
[Music]
easy easy what else I don't know why I
asked I don't really don't know why I
asked hey mister man oh if you goes up
and down okay
[Music]
okay you go over easy oh my god what is
this uh okay okay okay of course of
course how am I gonna do that if I can't
even do it normal what I didn't even
touch it
why aren't you double jumping
[Music]
my god it's not that hard you anime
loving piece of [ __ ] oh my god
do it man work a letter an nah come on
Felix come on [ __ ] stop touching it
what are you doing what are you doing
look how much you have left god damn
this is so tricky okay let's look at the
pattern yeah oh no you really hit the
pattern there you boy you really did a
good job there you [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god they go faster are you kidding
me are you kidding me
how am I supposed to do that oh this is
so hard I don't even know how I made it
here
what Oh watch me dying watch me [ __ ]
die
[Music]
I don't get it I don't [ __ ] get it
when do I go here there's like no space
to move there's like no [ __ ] space at
all oh my god here we are again here we
are again at the impossible yeah Wow
[Music]
I don't even know what kills me like is
there a spot I can stand there it seems
ah I'm pretty good at this bit now like
I can do this part but the thought there
this I don't get on like where where how
is it even physically possible
to go through that [ __ ] place how I
don't understand like there's nowhere to
go exactly between them but it's no time
there's just no time I just don't get it
man I play this 500 [ __ ] times I
thank you I don't understand
[Music]
yes [ __ ] yes
you saw it smooth that was oh my god
okay great we just gotta make it we just
gotta make it we just gotta make it to
the top
okay what's gonna happen the spikes are
gonna shoot me oh no not the specs [ __ ]
you oh my god what that I'm so [ __ ]
tired of this [ __ ]